yeah i've never really had bad
housemates i've just had housemates
didn't like pay bills
but there's ways of being able to get
them to pay bills yeah i think that's
why
i mean i would argue a housemate that
doesn't pay the bill as a bad house yeah
i would argue that as well
would you i'd rather because right what
we would what i would do is because i
was in charge of the internet
and i was the only one because like
these guys i mean they were my age but
they didn't they weren't like very
um knowledgeable about like yeah about
like technical
technical technology and like internet
stuff right and they didn't realize that
like if you had the password to the
internet you could log in and turn off
internet to certain devices
oh okay yeah did you know you could do
that yeah okay yeah so you can just type
in the like what is it like that
whatever the numbers are the 19 whatever
182 yeah and then you can log into the
internet yeah the ip address you log
into it and you can just turn off
devices so i would just they didn't pay
me i would just
turn off all their internet all their
devices that's literally the equivalent
of like
your mom taking your switch away because
you didn't do your chores it's like
until you do your chores
no more play time for you yeah and then
they would be like oh i've got an
assignment not much to pay me
i mean i'll put your internet back on
you know that's a power move dude well
yeah because i'm like they're not going
to pay me because
they were being [ __ ] so i was like
well i rightfully deserve you haven't
paid me for like half a month now uh
you know i'm we're all students i don't
have money like yeah this is
you know i'm paying a bill for four
people yeah you know you can't pay me
like 10 quids like
come on course well that's why like i
hated being
in charge of like when you're in
university were you the guy i'm guessing
you were the guy in charge of paying the
rent then
or was it just uh so the rent was
actually done separately but the bills
were done
through me okay and it was only in the
second house that i had a problem the
last house there's only
three of us they're already chill and
they all paid whenever i asked
uh but the house before that they just
never paid uh because they were just
spending it all on weed as they do
as they do yeah so i was like well i
mean all right well [ __ ] i mean
cause you always have that one house
made in uni that just was never there
and never paid for anything and you'd
like you'd have to [ __ ] hire a
private investigator or something to
like
get this get this guy's money or get
yeah get the money from that guy
it was weird man because like one of my
housemates he was like what
how old are you in second year like 20
barely 20 91 maybe yeah 20 yeah
he had he had his girlfriend was
pregnant and then
he had the baby and it was just still so
surreal when i'm like here barely have
my life in order and this man
brings his [ __ ] child into the room
and i'm like and then i'm like what's
going on this is so weird i don't i
don't
like this and then i felt bad asking for
internet money i'm like hey by the way
can you pay the bills
but uh i'm sure you can go like a week
without weeds
just just just pay me bro like give your
kids some starburst or something i don't
know like
just pay me i don't know i
got some top ramen left over you can
give it to your baby yeah yeah yeah and
also like i i think his girlfriend
basically lived at us
at our house and i was like should she
be paying some bills
i don't know i mean yeah to be fair
i was like i'm not gonna ask but i think
you should just pay me on time and we
got no problem yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
so annoying because they because it just
wouldn't get done right unless i did it
yeah of course
no we wouldn't have internet i'm like
well i want internet so i'm gonna do it
i'm gonna set it up oh
advertised in my name [ __ ] this or maybe
it was better that was inadvertently in
your name right
yeah well because then i cancelled it
all and i did it um and and all that
and right before we left that house the
one where they didn't pay the bills
they actually owed ours i think it was
something like 80 pounds in the end
uh in overdue bills and because we'd all
left the house i couldn't hound them i
messaged them on facebook and they
wouldn't send it to us
and so i had to pay it um and it was
actually me and my friend
who were the only ones who paid bills
and we were really we were really close
and i still hang out with him and still
message him sometimes
yeah um really good friends with them
and we both basically paid all our bills
and sold it all out and
yeah so we had to then pay the bills for
two months for the other guys you didn't
pay
yeah we were really annoyed about it
because we were trying them to pay and
they weren't paying us
and then i felt like some some cosmic
justice was was given because
and and yeah the god smiled down the
gods are like hold up connor
so it turns out right we'd actually
overpaid our bills right and then we got
a rebate so they had actually given us
money back
right which is actually more than what
we actually owed so
we ended up get given like 50 pounds
back
and my friend was like should we uh
should we give it like equally between
us all and like
do you think they would have done the
same i'm like let's just let's just
how about [ __ ] them this is 25 quid
let's just keep it let's just go to the
pub let's [ __ ] this hell yeah yeah they
weren't gonna pay us
i bet if you message them they would
have like replied at the speed of life
you know i do feel a little bit bad
about it before we require like can i
can i tell the story it's like
[ __ ] that i'm stealing i haven't done
the exact same thing yeah they would
have done the exactly they would have
done the exact same thing
yeah especially if they didn't pay you
as well exactly yeah they literally
wouldn't reply to all messages about
paying us back
i felt bad but i was also like because
like i just
would never ever steal but i was like no
but if they're not gonna follow the
rules then why should you follow the
rules
yeah all right i i feel i feel it's i
feel it's fair
yeah i guess so yeah yeah i i feel like
going through
rent drama or some kind of like bills
drama or university it's just like a
right of passage i feel like everyone's
had
at least one person that they've been
living with who has just been like the
most
difficult [ __ ] to [ __ ] get
any kind of money out of i know i don't
i just feel bad because i feel like i'm
better than that yeah
i don't do this i wake up on a cold
sweat i'm like what's the statute
of limitations of stealing
i don't know because even though it's a
small amount as well i just i felt bad
but i was like you know what no [ __ ]
them
it's literally like that that good kid
does one bad thing and it's like oh [ __ ]
there's a police
you know what i mean that's called karma
man
oh [ __ ] i should never did that i don't
know
yeah it was very very it's very
validating but it was also like [ __ ] i
go to jail
what's the limit to stealing before the
cops get called on me
it's like one week i'm good right i'm
free i'm free